there's two reasons why men are  feminized we live in a femme-centric  society men are being raised by women  when they're not at home then they're in  school being taught and raised by women  in a world whereby everything is catered  to women by the messaging from the media  is don't be toxically masculine it's  okay to cry it's okay to show your  feelings they're like pushing all this  like feminine energy  um onto men and I don't think that is  just a uh a coincidence I think the  reason they're doing this is because men  used to be a lot more masculine they  used to be a lot stronger they used to  be a lot more disagreeable it's the men  that go to war and it's the men that  fight so when tyranny comes it's the men  that go first and so if you're able to  control the men and you're able to  feminize the men then you're able to  control Society to a much greater extent